Now the answer I was looking for in this question, is
that it would be most likely mutation in the coding region,
not the non-coding region. There were several levels by which you
could have addressed the y part of the question. And I've
come up with three different answers, an OK, a better and
a best answer to the y question. I'm going to read these
and I want you to evaluate your own answer against these
possible answers. An OK answer would have been that the coding
region mutations change proteins. Okay. Sure. So
what? A better answer would have said that
coding region mutations alter amino acid sequence
and thus protein function. Gives me some idea
that, you understand the full impact of
the mutation. But it doesn't really juxtapose the
notion of what a coding region mutation
does and why a non-coding mutation wouldn't better
describe this. So the best answer would be that a
coding region mutation is more likely to alter amino acid
sequence. And thus the function of the protein compared to
a non-coding mutation, which is more likely to affect the
expression of a functioning and intact protein. Go ahead and
rank your answer somewhere on the spectrum here, from OK
to better to best. And you can pick check boxes
in between. Go ahead, tell me how you think you did.